he says but i don't want you to ever
think like that we didn't love each
other enough or we didn't spend enough
time with one another
because you regret that every day
he says it's okay
[Music]
hey it's matt frazier and i'm backstage
right now at the kelly clarkson show and
i gotta tell you i'm seeing a lot more
than just the living people i'm looking
down the hallway here and there are a
ton of dead people so we're gonna see
who's here first of all it's funny
because like just how you're all lined
up here before we start the show like
your loved ones are lined up on the
other side and right away like your
grandmother is here stepping forward
letting you know that she's here and
with you and she's like so proud of you
when i'm connecting with her and i gotta
tell you her fondest memories of you
were when you were just a little girl
because she tells me that you used to
stay with her and like she used to take
care of you back when you were younger
because she showed me like you being
younger and like her touching your hair
and the things that she used to do with
you she says and i want you to know she
says that i've been watching over you
ever since my departure she says so
please let her know that i am okay and
that more importantly she knows that you
think about her every day because she
says to me that you think about her in
the car and you think about her when
you're driving she says i want you to
know that i'm right there this is my
phone screen you can't see it
this is my grandma
oh my god
so no it's her way of just acknowledging
and you take it out and just talk to her
and talk to that picture
know that your grandmother knows that
you have that phone and i gotta tell
your brother's here and because he kept
saying like that's my sister and he's a
hot [ __ ] when i'm connecting with him on
the other side how old was he when he
departed
44 when he passed but when i'm
connecting with him it's funny because
your brother looks younger to me like he
looks so much younger when i'm
connecting with him i feel like he never
grew up to be like 44 like i feel like
he always just stayed with the times
when i'm speaking to him
and he says to me can i just have your
hand for a minute he says to me the
first thing that he wants you to know is
sorry for everything that you had to
witness with his departure because it
all happened so quickly and he passed in
tragedy here in the physical world so
your brother says to me that the first
thing that he wants you to know is that
not only he's here but also wants to
thank you for stepping forward and
keeping the family together here in the
physical world he tells me he was just
like going through pictures of him or
like looking at pictures of him
because he talks about the collage are
you making the collage
that's all right and did you wait a
minute and he told me did you ever get
the tattoo in memory of him
no but i was going to it's my birthday
he said you better not get that tattoo
he says my he says my sister needs to
stop he says trying to remember me in
all these ways he says you've already
done so much and he's acknowledging that
he says all i want he says is for you to
know that i am at peace your family was
very religious here in the physical
world so i'm connecting with him he says
listen i believed in god i believed in
the other side
he says and i want you to know that i am
okay
because he's acknowledging that to me
you know i know that there was an age
difference between the two of you here
in the physical world he says but i
don't want you to ever think like that
we didn't love each other enough or we
didn't spend enough time with one
another
because you regret that every day
he says it's okay
he says listen this is why he's coming
through
you know he tells me that you think all
the time about his departure
and you've been suffering with this for
so long and this is just your way to
know that you can live life again and
that he's here
he really is here
and he stinks when i'm connected with
him he's got all this kelowna and when
i'm speaking to him what was with mixing
the colognes and wearing all different
colognes
yo this is freaking wild
cause he's got like all of these bottles
these mix i'm feeling like i'm having
like old spice and like pierre content
like all these weird things that he
smells like i'm like are you kidding me
right now he would like he would own
like 17 bottles of bond and all these
other like expensive like colognes and
like layer them on like that's what i'm
saying like that's wild this is freaking
wild your grandfather's stepping forward
and when i'm connecting with him he told
me there was heart issues that he was
dealing with here in the physical world
what was the heart issues with the heart
problems i don't know if that's my
grandfather or my dad oh your dad also
departed
from a heart attack that would be who it
is
because when i'm connecting i such a
feel things and i just felt like my
heart started to fluctuate and then he
said to me i like i felt like he almost
died years earlier but then was able to
recover from this so in other words they
were keeping an eye on his heart do you
understand that how long ago did your
dad depart 10 years i gotta tell you
he's making me step forward and speak
because i feel like there's still a
mystery over his passing meaning that
even though that your dad had died he
said to me i never expected to die at
this time
you know your dad tells me that he was
sick that whole week i know what had
happened he just said to me that he was
that he had just gone to the doctors it
was just at the doctors like i felt like
that week or the week prior
before he had died
because he said to me
go ahead he
was not
here in l.a with my family
and he died
one night right back
and my mom that day that he had he had
been saying that he had been having
pains in his chest all day and my mom
said when you get back you need to take
you to the doctor
[Music]
and he had never made it i mean
because your dad says to me that you
think about this all the time and you
think well maybe if we got him to the
doctor sooner there was something that
could have been done
you ask your father all the time or you
say to him i wish i could hug him one
more time your dad just asked me to give
you a hug from him
i know that he is with you the biggest
thing then when i think of him is i
think of his hubs he said that and i
feel like every time i think about it
i'd like to poke him in my mind he said
to me you ask him all the time can i
just want one more hug with him so for
him to make me come over here and hug
you it's his way of just acknowledging
that and letting you know that you know
he is so proud of you oh there's one
other thing he reaches your music so if
you hear music though oh my god
that's his way of just letting you know
that he's there because he said to me
like i have he plays songs that has
songs in memory of me
for my like me and my sister it's like
we hear him through music well thank you
for letting me channel him for you you
know and i hope that brings you a little
bit of healing knowing that he's with
your grandfather as well so we haven't
even started the show yet so we're gonna
go and do that now
this is crazy i just walked out of my
dressing room right now and then
literally there's like a line full of
dead people wanting to talk so we're
gonna go get start the show and uh we'll
see on the kelly clarkson show
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going